my government continues to deny
shroud
hey guys pete here today i thought i'd
do a video looking at the changes the tv
series made in adapting isaac asimov's
foundation series there's been a lot of
somewhat heated discussions and mixed
reactions about the adaptation so i
thought i'd get down what actual changes
they made i won't go deep into some
things because i don't want to spoil the
big picture but with that said there are
definitely spoilers from the first two
episodes so if you haven't watched them
then this video won't be for you whether
you're new to the series or it's just
been a while since you read it this
should cover the important parts and
filter out some of the noise noise that
i should say isn't surprising foundation
is a series that has been popular for a
long time and that means that people do
have expectations then you also have
some groups that are always present on
the internet especially with something
like this in my experience anyways as
someone who has to read a lot of youtube
comments you have the people who see
everything through the cultural war lens
who tend to get upset about things like
representation and diversity and then
you have people who love the source
material to the point of being purest in
that they don't want to see any changes
at all so yeah none of that surprising
but it also isn't specific to foundation
so it doesn't really say much either i
guess i was more surprised at the amount
of people saying it doesn't resemble
azimov's original work at all partially
because the author changed a lot of
things himself when he revisited the
universe to write the prequels and
sequels when he merged it with the robot
series he altered several fundamental
ideas that reflect how his thinking on
things had evolved and then i guess
what's more important for this video i
found it surprising because the actual
events of the first story the psycho
historians were mostly intact especially
harry selden's introduction and his
trial and i suppose that's the best
place to start since that involves gail
dornick who's a character that embodies
both sides of the argument on the one
hand her role in relation to the plot is
almost identical at least in the very
beginning and on the other she's kind of
connected to all the different changes
we see in one way or another so the most
obvious thing about gail that's changed
for anyone who's read the series is that
gal dornick was originally a man this is
one of the three major gender swaps for
the tv show with the other two being
salvor hardin and edodemerzel
introducing some female characters was
probably inevitable if not necessary
since there aren't any to speak of in
this part of the story and gal is a
pretty good candidate all things
considered he's really a blank slate we
don't learn much about him in the short
period of time that he's in the story
other than him being a mathematician
initially the character only played a
role in the first story of the first
book in the series it's an introduction
to the series that was written after the
fact it's the first one you read but the
last one that was written it was added
to tie things together and to open the
novel after all the short stories were
collected so the character basically
functioned as a representation of the
reader gal comes from synax is swept up
into this situation with harry selden
and you get to be introduced to the
empire's capital planet trantor through
his eyes and get an idea of who harry
seldon is and what he's trying to do
with psycho history if gal was a blank
slate the next major change is that gail
definitely has a backstory she's still
from synax which we never really learned
much about in the books but there was no
impression that it was like what we see
on the show part of why you need a
backstory for this character is that it
seems pretty evident that the show's
gonna keep her around for a lot longer
at the end of episode 2 we saw her being
put into what looked like suspended
animation and in the narration we've
heard her speaking about things that
happen in the future as if she
experienced them so we can put two and
two together there
another change is that we see her get
involved with rach who's a character
that's been pulled forward in the
timeline from the prequels rach and
demerselle aren't in the original
trilogy both of them were introduced in
prelude to foundation which is also
where cleon the first comes from and
we'll come back to him in a minute rach
is depicted mostly the same although he
is missing his thick dalite mustache
which was basically his trademark in the
books as a child harry found him in a
rough part of the lower levels on
trantor and adopted him he grew up got
married and had two kids giving hairy
grandchildren they seem to be merging
that part of his story with gales and
the major change for him is that he
didn't kill harry on the way to terminus
actually none of them were involved in
the journey that the show has depicted
as a years-long trip on a slow ship the
trip happened off page in between
stories in the books and there's really
nothing else said about it rach was dead
by then and it was never harry's plan to
make the trip he died himself of old age
not long after they left in the epilogue
to the prequel forward the foundation
it's mentioned that gao traveled
determinus just before harry's death in
relation to the book's version of the
vault but he wasn't involved with the
initial formation of the colony and
there was a thing where rach was briefly
brainwashed to kill harry at one point
which sounds kind of funny out of
context but the plan was stopped and it
wasn't anything like what happened in
the show plus rache's daughter was fully
grown up by the end of the second
prequel so no slow ship no murder no
device behind the ear and no cryopod or
whatever it is that rach put gail in at
the end in the beginning she also
traveled to trantor on a jump ship and
that's quite a bit different than
hyperspace travel in the books which has
been around long enough that it's just a
thing that exists and you don't have to
do the whole going to sleep thing at the
beginning of the story it's just
something that people do unless you
never go into space and you've never
tried it you don't really think too much
of it i mentioned that we didn't learn
much about synax in the books and this
whole idea of the seer church is
completely made up for the show there
are religions and different cultures and
things like that but this one is just
specifically towards gayle's story and
there's also this strange thing about
her where she seems to be able to sense
things before they happen obviously this
character didn't have anything like this
in the book and there really wasn't
anything like this with the early
characters but for people who've read
the entire series it's pretty clear
where this is going so it's not
completely out of the blue
the final thing with gail is that when
the emperor was asking them why he
shouldn't just kill them it was harry
that said it would accelerate the
collapse the show switched that to gail
which might not mean anything or it may
be something that he hadn't anticipated
that might create ripple effects down
the road beyond the stuff i've already
mentioned about his death and being on
the trip to terminus in the first place
harry as a character isn't changed much
at all in fact some of his dialogue is
pulled straight from the books and
overall what we've seen so far is
consistent with how you're introduced to
him there the emperor on the other hand
is the last major change as i mentioned
cleon the first was in prelude demisel
was his first minister and he did meet
with harry when he first heard about
psycho history this was right after
harry arrived on trantor as a young man
in his 30s though and the ruler didn't
see much use for his research at the
time it wasn't very developed yet the
emperor in the show is a clone of that
same cleon and there are three of them
at three different ages in power
together at any given time brother dawn
the youngest and brother dusk who is the
oldest with day sitting on the middle
throne where he's the ruler with the
final say they age out and the cycle
continues with demerizel assisting in
the process since she's a robot and
doesn't age like a human she's been
involved since the beginning outlasting
them all and there's a change with her
and that cleon never knew the male
version of demarzel was a robot in the
books
the genetic dynasty is a big change in
that they have absolute control over the
empire in his books asimov based his
galactic empire on the romans it was
basically a plutocracy where the rich
and powerful ran things and at the time
that the psycho-historian story took
place the emperor was just a puppet
the show introduced the dynasty for the
same reason it seems to have kept gail
in the story beyond her natural lifespan
to give a century-long story some
consistency of characters that viewers
can get to know and that'll be there
throughout multiple seasons i think it's
too early to tell how well that will
work out there's definitely a chance
that it only goes off the rails from
here having three clones where they all
have a sense of wanting to make their
own mark seems better than just having
one it also puts a face on the problems
of an empire that's collapsing which may
work out better than just introducing
different members of the aristocracy
over time either way the point is that
the empire is no longer effective and
those in power will make the fall worse
for everyone in their unwillingness to
let go of it there's really not much
there to go off of yet the one thing
we've seen that was added to the show is
the conflict between anacrion and
thespis and of course the starbridge
attack brother day took that as an
opportunity to show their strengths and
to warn other worlds what'll happen if
they go against the throne and acreon is
part of the story and this might tie
into the role they play but what we've
seen so far isn't in the books at all
the last thing before i wrap it up is
the vault on terminus in the show the
settlers found it when they arrived on
the planet and it's this hovering sort
of diamond shaped thing it likely serves
the same purpose as it does in the book
so i won't spoil that but as i mentioned
gail dornick went to the planet to set
it up it wasn't a secret it wasn't found
there and it wasn't mystical in any way
it was just a part of the plan for
terminus and the foundation's
development so there are a lot of
changes but if you pull back i think you
can imagine how they're drawing on
things that asimov introduced it's still
about harry's predictions and the plan
he came up with so to me it seems like
an overreaction to say it's nothing like
the original story and i will say that
it was jarring for me the first time i
watched it it takes some effort to
separate what i'm seeing for what it is
instead of how it compares to my
expectations i do think changes were
necessary and even beyond the basic
things that go along with adapting from
one medium to the other i think they
identified some of those things and
they're making an effort to find
solutions it's still really difficult to
make a great tv show and i don't think
that that's guaranteed here the show
looks great i think it did some things
well in the first two episodes but we'll
just have to wait and see and i think
that's a good place to leave it so let
me know in the comments what you're
thinking about which changes worked
which changes didn't and what you're
hoping to see going forward please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon